este es el primer acto por la memoria la
verdad y la justicia en argentina luego
de dos años de pandemia los que no se
pudo llevar a cabo ese un acto en el que
el país masivamente aquí en la plaza de
mayo recuerda el inicio del golpe
militar de
1976 que causó numerosas muertes 30 mil
desaparecidos
por ellos se hace este acto por ese
recuerdo por la memoria porque no se
repita lo que ocurrió entre
1976 y
1983 es un año también especial porque
las madres de plaza de mayo las abuelas
de plaza de mayo están viendo cómo pasan
la posta de su lucha a las nuevas
generaciones que es algo muy importante
para ellos y también es un acto muy
especial porque este año se cumplen 40
años de la guerra de malvinas esa guerra
que llevó adelante esa dictadura militar
y que de alguna forma se entiende que
terminó forzando y ayudando y se
terminará la realidad de ese gobierno de
facto que se habían puesto en el palacio
y que tanta muerte que tanto dolor había
causado a los argentinos un dolor que
todavía persiste como puede verse en
este acto aquí en la plaza